hi guys i got a little trick for you
today a lot of you been asking me to
play more scary games and more let's
plays so i found this cool game called
alice mare
grave and it hasn't been two done before
it's kind of like an exploration horror
game
like if you like it let me know and i'll
carry on doing it so
let's see how it goes the ant told me
that the frog is bad
the frog told me that the cat is bad the
cat told me
no the rabbit is the worst of them all
so i what did you do
what did you do
that's roughly how life will be here for
you
okay if you don't understand there's a
number in your room
that explains it all again no one will
ask anything if you hear
there are a few things to keep to but it
should be a peaceful life
an edition here receives the notebook
cool your own personal notebook use that
however you like
sad or happy times just write down any
feelings you have and give it to me
would you
haha but some children like to doodle in
it that's my mummy too
now there's still time before dinner you
should greet the other children
leave and go straight left you can find
your roots they're all good children
it may not be immediate per se but
you'll get along i'm sure
okay ah
and myself just call me teacher
i look forward to having you here alan
i'm a boy okay
it's over my voice by the way i'm a bit
ill something to speak ill normally
okay so who's this
stella
hello
oh that's odd that you can
speak why probably because
you don't really feel like you're alive
well
obviously i do or as i would not be
speaking would i
alan is it i'm stealing okay stella
you're weird
goodbye
sup my name's brown oh wait
was it marcus might have been nickel
island huh or maybe it was helen what
the hell is he all about
oh well nice to meet you at least he's
nice
oh it's teddy's i like this one
i'm chelsea
and nice to meet you okay
wow i've never seen you before oh you're
the one the teacher mentioned
call me lady there's also rick but he's
not here right now
he's a very nice boy brother and sister
then
and you are alan i'd be really happy if
we could play
nice to know you i'm just imagining
every guy
uh oh okay so i'm guessing this is my
bedroom
do's and don'ts avoid leaving your rooms
as
much as possible except during free time
potty breaks
okay don't take things from other rooms
don't break anything
ever if you do tell teacher don't force
your weighted up rooms don't hit
other people that's a good rule tell a
teacher about anything that troubles you
or that you want
at the very bottom a drawing of some
kind of rabbit
rabbit's the worst of all okay
yeah someone needs to go need to go
where
oh twilight
okay go to dinner this is like an
orphanage or something
teacher you've introduced yourself
how did it go i see i believe you can
carry some conversation with me
you're just in time for dinner let's go
to the dining room yes
i'm actually super hungry i just can't
be asked to cook anything
now what do you say thanks for that meal
teacher
my voice all right
return to your rooms and get ready to
bed you can go to each other's rooms to
talk but don't go to the second floor
i think i know where we're going
dismissed
you haven't been here long but you seem
used to things already
how are your memories doing memories
i see well no don't push yourself to
remember just take it nice and slow
i'm sure you remember everything what's
he on about memories
say do you want anything i'll buy
whatever i can afford ah
that's so cute ah wow
that i can't give you what did i ask for
it's not something you can buy sorry
i'll keep it in mind
well i'll buy you some new books you
love to read don't you allen
i'm impressed by how many words you can
understand already
like aren't these kids like i don't know
12
14 animes always look young anyway but
teachers not so smart i don't really get
difficult things
okay oh it's nothing alan if i
told you there was a world unlike our
world would you believe me
no it's just a fairy tale but
should you be invited to such a word i'd
advise against opening the door
why i think it's quite interesting
all right get back to your room i need
to look up to
get back to bed quick
we can talk to the other kids though
hello death lady quite a while ago i
said you felt the least alive out of
anyone
but actually teacher sinister seems
about equally devoid of life
perhaps it's his lack of cleanliness his
hair is so unkempt
it's even longer than mine i told him
that once
and he made a face like he'd eaten a
grapefruit
strange voices not interested what the
hell what the hell
she's weird oh it's this lash up
zebra oh she's got a different one
look at your stuff oh cool
i'm not playing anymore okay
look at this guys sup you talk to rick
he's around right now there's letty
and then there's this other guy he's
just all of a sudden
he's just there all of a sudden really
freaks you out pisses me off to no end
honestly
i like you what animals do you have
oh [ __ ]
lion that doesn't surprise me are you a
bear
i hear word voices joshua said that's
scary
i wonder if i can see it by myself ah
get over it
cats ah we love cats nice to meet you
no this is the first time we look rather
similar but i'm not letting
my name's rick and you're allen right
she told me about you when
goes to bed i watched the room for her
so it's like i watch her sleep
that's so weird well maybe it's not
quite that
oh well nice to meet you okay
what animals are you guys
dove oh that's quite nice okay
let's go back to my room
warm is that it just get into bed
the hell what do i do here did you know
there's weird voices coming from the
second floor at night
or like help uh
huh ugh no way i don't want to check out
for myself
if you're so curious why don't you go
alan oh but don't tell teacher he'll get
mad at me
okay okay i'll go
okay maybe not it suddenly got dark and
the music is stopped i don't want to go
anymore do i have to go
oh my god i don't want to move okay
let's talk to dead lady there you go
oh i thought she was going to put me at
ease but she doesn't
oh sorry okay stop whistling
oh my god
it's only a pixel game like it's so not
scary
help the butterfly
that wasn't scary hello
who's there oh
alan i heard a loud crash what are you
doing up here
didn't i tell you not oh to get ready
for bed and not go upstairs
the butterfly said help i see well
while that butterfly may look alive it's
long since
dead something with a soul can't speak
can it well according to the girl
downstairs it can speak
what a mess are you hot you seem fine
that's good
mine seems like a nice guy these glass
shards are dangerous
i'll clean them up so go to your room
and sleep
never mind it's just a little headache
no need to apologize really
just don't do it again there there there
there am i crying
no i'm so sorry it's okay
good night why am i crying what a [ __ ]
right
what's this thing don't worry i won
it might be his room
okay well that wasn't as bad as i
thought it was gonna be ah
i just like wind myself up
what's that noise is it raining outside
hey kitty what the hell
oh
do something okay oh [ __ ]
i thought it was gonna be like a jump
scare okay
what the hell is happening did i go to
bed
yap
jesus what the hey now if this
isn't a strange little human i've never
seen before
what's that why yes if you say you're
dreaming alice
then sure alice is this like alison
what's that
this is the truth my name is alan i'll
have you know because here
what alice says and does is everything
that's not your name oh no no alice
it's alice and that's because i say so
that contradicts what i said before
maybe you're onto the kid
this place is chock full of weirdos so
i'm just one of them
oh don't say that you don't stop in the
middle of a good meal dear
thanks for dreams gotta favor the taste
oh well i'm busier than i look all right
smile later that might be a pokemon
okay it's not as bad as i thought it was
gonna be so
far oh okay
this is like a graveyard
the writing is too messy to read
oh another visitor that makes six
that doesn't add up oh never mind
good evening alice and welcome i'm the
white rabbit i really like this i love
alice wonderland
the guide of these worlds it's a rather
big place so call me if you need
anything
unfortunately i can't move from this
spot it's a pain
it really is not to mention the massive
pressing of the keys to the world doors
going missing what four or five is
simply gone but i think i can hazard a
guess as to who has them
and as previously stated i cannot move
an inch
so alice i would like to ask you to how
does that sound
okay i don't i can actually say no okay
you have my thanks luckily i do have one
of the world keys in my hands
so you can already go in i was told not
to go through
doors knowing who you're dealing with
i'm sure
he scattered them all across the world
once you find one
please bring it back to me and don't be
shy about asking any other questions you
may have
but only this first time i don't care to
repeat myself again
and again that was
a this guy's in pain face just now
wasn't it
oh well i hope to have your assistance
well let's hope so okay right to
firefight
okay so i'm guessing this is the door
that i go through
there's it going frozen
oh my god what the hell i thought it
froze
i'm so confused you
you're doing well for yourself i'm
feeling bad
keys no not me no sir that's the truth
and nothing but
sure i did steal them but only because
somebody
asked me to can't tell you nope
i may be a liar but i won't lie to you
friend
yeah sure any other way to unlock him
no no of course not maybe if
you told me your mom made a name or the
name of your pet
funny whoops don't remember her oh yeah
okay besides i'm just a guide oh i give
a hint
hint it's a trail one world's key leads
to the next one
one by one eh why is that
i'm no more less of a pain wait i'm no
more or less a pain than that guy is
the white rabbit i mean ugh just saying
his name ruffles my fire
he's messed me up just as bad underneath
this hair hood
want to take a look it's a tiger test
for a little unlike you yeah go for it
all right thumbs up see you later
hey and good luck
thanks for the luck and stuff okay
what's this
one must not peer into the heart of a
man for the heart
is ever questioning up to two times can
be forgiven
but one who cannot answer the heart's
third question
what the hell will fall into an eternal
slumber
slumber
oh okay hey it's that bedroom what the
hell oh
morning alice hey hey hey i'm really
bored right now
so let's play let's play let's go okay
all right all right what should we do
want to open the closet
okay
spit alden
oh wait am i in bed [ __ ] i thought there
was someone else in bed
i'm so confused right now a small knife
we'll pick it up then
nothing's why is the nutcracker playing
oh my god i'm so weak i can't even pull
the leaves
oh have a taste
actually no leave them be
take the knife and cut the leaf
okay
my house is deep in the forest there are
lots of animals and the air is really
nice it's a wonderful place
my family is mother father and one more
he's always with me
he's there for me from good morning to
good night
but it's too bad he can't play tag or
anything with me oh so
it's the brother and sister why can't he
play tag with you then
hello
i i'll leave those mushrooms because
they look like they're going to kill me
to my family do you know where my gold
medal is
i had it in my pocket before bed if you
find it put it in the very top dresser
drawer on the left side
dad okay this is the dresser
dress the dresser i am dresser contents
none metal none
no none this is so cool
delicious looking mushrooms why don't
you eat these instead
that's lots okay what do you want me to
do here then
maybe i do eat the mushroom oh wait
eat them anyway go on
oh damn it i knew i would die
i didn't save her anything oh damn it
oh wait no i did
[ __ ] anyway i'm going to leave it here i
know it's not super scary yet but it is
said to be a horror so i'm sure it'll
come along the story but i love these
games because they've got brilliant
story lines
and they're just really cute and fun
like look at this how can you not like
this
so yeah let me know if you want to see
more uh i'll probably keep on playing
anyway for myself
so yeah have a lovely day or evening bye
ah okay
seriously in a bigger bedroom